the opening scene features Kate and her
husband John who arrive at the hospital
for the birth of their third child Kate
in labor is being wheeled towards the
delivery room while Jon contemplates the
registration process at the front desk
soon after Kate realizes that she's
bleeding but the nurse continues to push
the wheelchair without acknowledging the
issue in the delivery room Kate is in a
lot of pain and asks about Jon's
whereabouts but nobody answers the
doctor tells her to relax but she senses
something a Miss with her baby the nurse
then informs her that the baby is still
born but must be delivered anyway Kate
is in a state of disbelief and insists
that the baby is alive shortly after Jon
enters the room with a video camera
assuring Kate that everything is fine
just then the nurse hands Kate a
stillborn infant wrapped in a
bloodstained blanket overwhelmed with
horror she lets out a scream of Despair
John can't believe that he recorded over
Simpsons reruns for this in the next
scene Kate startles awake from a
nightmarish dream and leaves her bed
making her way to the bathroom there she
gazes at the scars on her belly and then
takes a pill the next morning she visits
her therapist Browning and talks about
her nightmares Browning suggests that
these nightmares can be linked to her
past stillbirth experience now that'll
be $300 or the impending adoption of a
child as their conversation deepens Kate
confesses that she passed by a liquor
store but managed to resist the
temptation to go inside hearing this
Browning mentions that if she can resist
that Temptation she's certainly capable
of being a strong adoptive mother
afterwards Kate goes to pick up her deaf
daughter Max from school on their way
back home she gets distracted by a
pregnant woman and nearly collides with
a truck later at home Kate tries to
compose a tune on the piano but her
concentration is disrupted by Max
playing with a basketball frustrated she
asks her her to stop and the girl
apologizes soon after JN arrives home
with their son Daniel and joins Max in
playing basketball after dinner Max
requests a bedtime story that's based on
a deceased child she inquires if she'll
have a new sister to which Kate replies
that it's uncertain the following
morning Kate and John visit an orphanage
where they're welcomed by Abigail she
guides them inside where Kate and
Abigail observe girls playing while Jon
is drawn to the sound of a girl singing
he follows the sound and finds a young
girl named Esther working on her
painting Jon is about to leave when
Esther greets him and shares the stories
behind her artworks not long after Kate
and Abigail join them and they engage in
a conversation with the girl Esther says
that nobody has ever spoken to her
before because she's different the
couple seems to like her so they decide
to adopt her following this they have a
discussion with Abigail who informs them
that Esther is a bright Russian girl
left at the orphanage after her her
Guardians passed away in a house fire
Abigail assures them that she'll start
the necessary paperwork soon so that
Esther can burn their house down too the
scene then shifts to 3 weeks later and
JN and Kate bring Esther to their home
Max excitedly welcomes them and Esther
uses sign language she learned on the
way to greet her back she also meets
Max's grandmother Barbara and everyone
offers her welcoming gifts however
Daniel doesn't look happy and becomes
envious when she gives his father a huge
thank you hug nobody hugs Daddy but me
later that day Daniel brings his friends
to his Treehouse where they go through
adult magazines while Esther and Max
play together in the snow at night as
John and Kate are making love the two
girls interrupt them they say that they
are scared of the lightning and want to
sleep with them the parents promptly
agree and Esther ends up sleeping next
to JN seeking comfort in his presence
the following morning as Kate prepares
Max and Daniel for school Esther
descends the stairs in a fancy dress
which amuses the two kids Kate suggests
that Esther change into a more
appropriate outfit for school but she
insists on wearing the dress Kate
eventually relents and drives all the
children to school at school when the
teacher introduces Esther to the class A
student named Brenda makes fun of her
dress however Esther just responds with
a stern look and proceeds to her seat
later that day Kate sees Esther and Max
playing on a frozen stream she hurries
outside urging them to get off the ice
and reprimands them for playing in a
dangerous area meanwhile Daniel is
playing with a paintball gun aiming at a
pigeon he hits the bird causing it to
suffer on the ground right then Max and
Esther approach him and the ladder hands
him a brick instructing him to end the
pigeon's suffering when Daniel refuses
Esther takes matters into her own hands
and smashes the pigeon mercilessly she
then heads to take a bath in the
meantime Kate enters Esther's room to
put away her laundry and one of the
drawers she discovers a Bible book with
a photo of a man she hastily puts the
book back to its hidden spot unbeknownst
to her Esther is watching her from the
bathroom the next day at school Daniel's
friends make fun of him because of
Esther so he intentionally knocks the
books from her hands as she Stoops to
pick them up Brenda seizes her Bible and
tosses it scattering its Pages Esther in
a state of distress hastily collects the
pages while doing so Brenda attempts to
remove the ribbon around Esther's neck
but the ladder scares Everyone by
letting out a loud scream like
this back at home Kate guides Esther in
playing the piano while also inquiring
about the school incident however the
little girl brushes off the conversation
insisting that there's nothing to talk
about changing the subject Esther asks
about Jessica saying that Max often
talks about her Kate then shows her the
place where Jessica her deceased baby's
ashes are buried among white roses later
after dinner thinking the children are
asleep Kate and John make love in the
kitchen these two are animals Esther
unexpectedly appears but she promptly
leaves the following morning Kate
approaches Esther to discuss the same
incident the girl appears unfazed and
casually mentions that she's aware of
intimate activities as well as the
fword fabulous later the parents have a
discussion about it with Kate suggesting
that they take Esther to see Browning
however Jon thinks that this is
overreacting to take the child to
therapy for just one dirty word he and
Kate fabulous in the kitchen all the
time later on he takes his children to a
nearby park where their neighbor Joyce
approaches him and begins to flirt
Esther Eaves drops on their conversation
and simultaneously spots Brenda she
gives her a cold look which makes the
bully nervous as Brenda prepares to
descend from the slide Esther shoves her
from behind causing her to break her leg
Max Witnesses this but Esther instructs
her to keep it a secret that evening
over dinner the parents question Esther
about the incident involving Brenda she
claims it was an accident which Max
confirms while they dine Daniel taunts
Esther and begins calling her names
prompting the parents to berate him
enraged Daniel swears at her and leaves
the table stating that Esther is not his
sister as a punishment for his
inappropriate behavior John locks
Daniel's Treehouse later Kate is at the
grocery store with her two daughters
when she receives a call from Abigail
the latter asks about Esther taking this
opportunity Kate steps aside and
discloses all the incidents that have
transpired lately meanwhile Max reads
her lips and conveys the information to
Esther once they are back home the weird
girl surprises Kate by playing the piano
flawlessly intrigued Kate questions her
about why she pretended not to know how
to play to which Esther responds that
she did it for her that same night Kate
complains to her husband about the girl
which results in a heated argument
between the two Esther overhears them
and seems to be happy a few days later
Abigail visits their residence she
speaks with the couple expressing her
concerns that something may be wrong
with Esther she even lists some past
incidents where the girl tried to hurt
other children hearing this Kate once
again urges Jon to take Esther to see
Browning and this time he agrees
meanwhile the weird girl overhears their
conversation and becomes scared so she
rushes to Max and seeks her help the two
girls then locate the keys to the
Treehouse and Esther uses them to
retrieve a gun from Jon's safe she loads
the gun with a bullet and points it at
Max scaring the little girl after this
they hide at a nearby bridge waiting for
Abigail's car to pass Esther instructs
Max to stand in front of her car and
wave to stop her shortly after Abigail
approaches but Max hesitates to move as
a result Esther pushes her onto the road
causing Abigail to slam on the brakes
and swerve off the road when she rushes
to check on Max Esther strikes her with
a hammer rendering her unconscious she
then forces Max to help in moving the
body before anyone sees them together
they push Abigail down a hill but she
regains Consciousness seeing this Esther
repeatedly strikes her head with the
hammer until she stops breathing Max
goes to get the parachute pants after
this gruesome act the two girls go to
the treehouse where Esther hides her
blood stained clothes and the hammer
while Max continues to cry to keep this
incident a secret Esther scares Max
claiming that she could also go to jail
for assisting her in the crime as they
climb down the Treehouse Daniel spots
them from a distance and Esther notices
him too that night she sneaks into his
room and holds him at knife Point
threatening him not to utter a word
Daniel is so terrified that he wets
himself in the next scene Kate and Jon
take Esther to to see Browning the
therapist talks to the girl while the
couple Waits outside later on Browning
assures them that the child is fine and
suggests that Kate might be projecting
feelings of inadequacy as a mother onto
Esther excuse me Jon agrees with
his assessment after which they depart
back home Kate receives a call from the
orphanage informing her that Abigail
hasn't returned yet the case involves
the police and they soon find Abigail's
dead body though presently there are no
suspects meanwhile Esther is seen in her
room repeatedly switching the aquarium
light on and off revealing a disturbing
painting of a house and a family
afterwards Kate researches on signs of
disturbed children and shares her
findings with johon relating it to
Esther's Behavior concerned for their
children's safety Kate contacts the
Russian orphanage from which Esther came
but much to her surprise she learns that
there's no record of Esther the next day
Kate drops off Daniel and Max at school
but before leaving she inquires if
Esther has caused them any harm but they
both lie and respond negatively later in
the evening Esther offers Kate some
white roses she picked from Jessica's
grave this triggers Kate's anger and she
grabs the girl's arm forcefully hearing
the commotion Jon intervenes and Esther
runs away she then sneaks into the tool
shed and deliberately fractures her own
arm later she calls Jon sobbing and
claiming her arm still hurts sensing a
serious injury he takes her to the
doctor after the medical examination Jon
tucks Esther into his bed as Kate enters
the room he confronts her but she
asserts that she didn't grip Esther's
arm that hard later an upset Kate
contemplates turning to alcohol but she
manages to control herself and pours the
wine down the sink the following morning
she takes the three children to school
as Daniel walks out of the car his bag
rips so Kate steps out to help him at
that moment Esther releases the car's
break causing it to to start rolling
with Max inside seeing this Kate runs
after the car until it's stopped by a
large pile of snow she quickly retrieves
Max who is thankfully unharmed later
that night Browning is summoned to the
house to speak with Kate she defends
herself insisting that she didn't harm
Esther and had properly placed the car
in park Jon then shows the two wine
bottles on the table revealing that
Esther had found them Kate attempts to
clarify her perspective but they don't
believe her the therapist then informs
her that she has reserved a spot for her
at the rehab center when she refuses to
go Jon warns her that he'll file for
divorce and take the children with him
meanwhile Max EES drops on their
conversation and Esther approaches her
Whispering that she'll shoot her mother
if she reveals anything afterwards
Daniel goes to Max's room and asks if
she knows anything about Esther Max
confesses the truth by making drawings
that depict each incident when she
informs him about the items hidden in
the treehouse he decid decides to
retrieve them as evidence to confront
Esther unbeknownst to them the evil
overhears their entire discussion they
really need to start checking around the
corner before bringing her up the next
day Kate checks Esther's room and
discovers the Bible book with a
reference to the SAR Institute She
searches for this name online and
contacts the provided number only to
learn that it's actually a mental
hospital in the meantime Daniel sneaks
into the Treehouse to gather evidence
Esther follows him there and starts it's
pouring gas over the evidence she Burns
it all setting the Treehouse Ablaze she
then locks Daniel inside it with the
intention of burning him alive in a
desperate bid to save himself Daniel
climbs to the top but he slips and Falls
rendering himself unconscious as Esther
prepares to finish him off with a large
Rock Max pushes her away just then Kate
notices the fire and runs to the scene
Daniel is rushed to the hospital where
the doctor delivers the Grim news the bo
boy has suffered a severe neck injury
concerned for their children's safety
Jon again urges Kate to seek
Rehabilitation this time she agrees but
on the condition that Esther leaves the
house as the two are arguing the girl
stealthily enters Daniel's room and
attempts to suffocate him with a pillow
but at the same time the alarm goes off
prompting the doctors to rush in
fortunately they managed to resuscitate
him suspecting that Esther is behind all
of this Kate slaps her hard but this
only results in her being restrained
Sedated by the hospital staff that night
JN returns home with Max and Esther
while Kate is admitted to the hospital
later she receives a call from Dr vava
from the SAR Institute who reveals that
Esther has a hormonal disorder called
hypopituitarism here it's revealed that
Esther is in fact a 33-year-old woman in
a young girl's body vava urgently
advises Kate to stay away from the girl
and call the cops he further reveals
that Esther was one of their most
violent patients who has killed several
people this freaks Kate out prompting
her to rush back home meanwhile Esther
is seen removing her false teeth and
wiping off her makeup that's making her
look young a short time later Jon enters
her room only to discover her disturbing
paintings on her way Kate attempts to
call Jon but the power goes out before
he can answer he then slowly makes his
way downstairs to the electrical panel
but he's suddenly attacked by Esther who
repeatedly stabs him to death realizing
that Max is witnessed the entire ordeal
she then goes after her upon arriving at
home Kate discovers Jon's lifeless body
a sight that shatters her emotionally
after a period of grieving she remembers
her daughter and proceeds to look for
her before she can locate Max Esther
intercepts her and shoots her in the
shoulder despite this Kate manages to
climb out of a window and hides there
just then she spots Max hidden among the
plants seeing Esther approaching him
Kate shouts from above prompting her to
fire a shot through the glass roof the
impact shatters the glass causing Kate
to fall onto Esther resulting in both of
them losing Consciousness shortly after
Max awakens Kate and the two make a run
for the forest leaving Esther behind the
police arrive and enter the house but
Esther is no longer there turns out that
she's chasing Max and Kate with a knife
following this Kate and Esther tumble
onto a frozen pond and engage in a
fierce brawl at this same time Max
retrieves the gun and fires a shot
cracking the ice beneath them both women
plunge into the freezing water but the
struggle continues at last Kate finally
manages to defeat the evil girl by
kicking her inside the water the police
also arrive at the scene bringing the
movie to an end subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching